2014 has been an amazing year I don't
usually say this but it might actually
be the best of all of them what I was
really excited about it was our opening
show that had 3d projection mapping it
was kind of an all-nighter so the the
crew that I was responsibly responsible
for this it took them till next morning
so that we really only saw it for the
first time at eight-fifty which was 40
minutes before we went to the actual
opening of the conference so I was so
glad it worked but i think was awesome
and i'm excited what we come up for next
year to outdo ourselves
you
hi I'm young I'm giving a talk about
with audio I fat end that jazz conf two
years ago and for the first time and
ever since I saw Stewart memos talking
Web Audio I was hooked I think Jess come
physical conference to actually get
started with speaking like it's they're
very open for speakers that haven't
spoken anywhere else before and I think
with today we've seen many people that
haven't spoken before any other
conference at all and they give you a
lot of feedback up front they help you
they make lists for you and I think is
perfect for for people who want to try
to talk although it's quite a big
conference but it's very open for that
I gave a talk about how I changed
careers in one year from no programming
experience at all to a hired program it
was rough it was hard but my talk is
about how I got so much help from so
many people in the community and how
awesome that was and trying to inspire
other people to help out I don't know
the whole atmosphere is just so friendly
and welcoming and all the talks have
been great and just with people seem
great
it seems like a really unique
opportunity it's a great conference very
well organized and it's just a really
interesting mix of people and I studied
Harry Potter in school so i wrote my
honors thesis on Harry Potter and when I
saw that the conference was asking for
speakers I thought maybe I could somehow
find a correlation between my learnings
from Harry Potter and how I could
related to JavaScript
um once I got past the initial nerves
once I stopped feeling like I was going
to throw up I think my talk went went
okay people laughing in the funny bits
and didn't laughter the not funny bits
which it's as best as I can expect
really live demo almost failed but it
worked in the end there are a few
conferences i have in my head as my
favorites in europe and this is my first
time at jess convey you and it's right
in at number one
my name is Rosie Campbell I'm a research
technologist at BBC research and
development and i'm here at descon
giving a talk called divining for
displays that don't exist yet yeah ah
they treat you like VIPs it's free and
I've just had such a great time and it's
such an ultra-cool conference as well I
mean like the music and the light and
the food and the drinks everything I
don't I don't quite feel like um cool
enough you know need like better facial
hair i think more elaborate facial hair
maybe
you